[Musique]
je suis avec Dimitri Seb Alex et Enzo
ils font partie du groupe premier métro
il participe au Versailles live à un
tremplin des voies organisé à Versailles
et dédié aux jeunes talents du
territoire on a trop trop hâte là
franchement on va jouer là tout à
l'heure sur la grande scène et avec les
gars on est trop chaud on a envie de se
lâcher tout péter quels sont les styles
musicaux justement que vous allez
aborder ce soir principalement du rock
après on fait aussi un peu de la pop des
synthé un peu années 80 et le but c'est
que tout le monde passe un bon moment
qu'on danse ensemble
chaque membre du groupe se met des
paillettes sous les yeux avant les
concerts pourquoi est-ce que vous vous
faites ça bah alors en fait les
paillettes c'est des paillettes c'est
des larmes de paillettes en fait qu'on
se trace sous les yeux et c'est parce
qu'en fait on a fait tellement la teuf
jusqu'à 5 6 du match en fait que les
paillettes elles ont coulées pendant
toute la nuit et c'est le maquillage
voilà de fin de teuf qu'on se met sous
les yeux ça nous fait un petit temps
avec les gars pour être tu vois
tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Versailles live c'est maintenant
[Musique]
c'est que je suis encore parti
est-ce que vous connaissez ce groupe
avant de participer au Versailles live
on l'adore
alors ce concert un truc de ouf c'était
trop trop bien les émotions là
tranquille
ils sont ils sont trop à fond et c'est
émouvant tu vas toucher ouais vraiment
musical le groupe premier métro gagne un
chèque de 1500 euros ils seront
également à la prochaine édition de la
Fête de la Musique à Versailles on n'a
pas fini de parler d'eux puisqu'ils vont
sortir un EP en début 2024